die idylle ist trügerisch
harry ton nimmt uns mit auf eine fahrt
durch das dorf knapp 40 km nordwestlich
der atomruine von fukushima ist einer
der am stärksten radioaktiv belasteten
orte japans ständiger begleiter des
78-jährigen ein geigerzähler an einem
offiziellen messpunkt steigt herr ito
aus
seht her sagt er mein messgerät zeigt um
50 prozent höhere werte an als das
offizielle wir fahren weiter am
straßenrand schwarze säcke mit
kontaminierter erde die zwar abgetragen
aber nicht abtransportiert wurde
etwas oberhalb des ortes kurz vor einem
checkpoint der polizei hätte ito wieder
an das ergebnis seiner messung dort aufs
jahr gerechnet das zweieinhalbfache des
japanischen grenzwert von 20
millisievert das 50-fache des
internationalen standards olympia als
wiederaufbau spiele zu bezeichnen ist
eine farce was ist hier in fukushima den
wieder aufgebaut
noch immer können 28.000 menschen nicht
zurück in ihrer heimat weil es zu
gefährlich ist
fukushimas strahlendes erbe ins schwarze
säcke verpackt und auf riesigen hallen
zwischengelagert
aber selbst dort wo schon mehrfach
dekontaminiert wurde wie im
landwirtschaftlich geprägten minamisoma
macht die strahlenbelastung dauerhaftes
leben eigentlich unmöglich weil den
behörden hier kaum noch jemand vertraut
ist eine bürgerinitiative lieber selbst
immer wenn es im wald oben in den bergen
windet und regnet bringen wind und
wasser die radioaktivität herunter ins
dorf die werte sinken einfach nicht wie
soll man ihr leben
regelmäßig nehmen sie zusätzlich
bodenproben weil es keine permanenten
dekontaminierung maßnahmen mehr gibt
sind die werte auch vor dem haus des
ortsvorstehers hoch die strahlung war in
den ersten sieben jahren nach der
katastrophe runtergegangen dann
stagnierte sie und nun steigt sie wieder
vermutlich wegen der rückbauarbeiten am
atomkraftwerk
dabei wird radioaktivität freigesetzt
die der wind dann hierhin trägt trotzdem
wurden evakuierungsanordnung 'nen nach
und nach aufgehoben und damit auch
entschädigungszahlungen der regierung
eingestellt der ehemalige bürgermeister
von minamisoma ist wütend
bei dem bemühen die olympischen spiele
zu bekommen und durchzuführen hat die
regierung ihre bemühungen die region von
fukushima wieder aufzubauen leider
vollständig aus dem fokus verloren
noch immer sind viele orte in der nähe
der atomruine geisterstädte buddha bar
okuma tomioka von wiederaufbau keine
spur
ein auf den ersten blick etwas anderes
bild in den vom tsunami verwüsteten
küstenregionen neue zehn und mehr meter
hohe welle schützen das hinterland in
minami sanriku wurde nur der
fischereihafen in der kleinen bucht
wieder aufgebaut der rest des ehemaligen
ortszentrums aufgeschüttet wasserphobie
yamauchi ist fischhändler er lebt vom
meer und ist geblieben obwohl er sich
keine illusionen macht wenn es noch
einmal einen tsunami mit ähnlichen
ausmaßen gibt wird auch dieses gebiet
mit dem markt wieder weggespült aber
dank der baulichen maßnahmen können wir
dann wenigstens unser leben retten
heute gemahnt dass damals zerstörte
evakuierungszentrum an die ungeheure
kraft des meeres der japan vor allem
beton entgegen zu setzen versucht die
gigantischen schutzmauern sind das
weithin sichtbare zeichen des
wiederaufbaus vielen menschen aber hat
das offensichtlich zu lange gedauert
oder sie haben das vertrauen in das
leben am meer verloren und sind weiter
hoch in die berge oder ganz weggezogen
auf eilig an höher liegenden orten
errichtete siedlungen wurden die
menschen aus den katastrophengebieten
verteilt aus ihrer gewohnten umgebung
und ihren sozialen strukturen gerissen
anders als die meisten materiellen
schäden der großen flut sind die
seelischen noch lange nicht behoben
manche menschen haben in dieser
katastrophe an einem einzigen tag ihre
gesamte familie verloren und waren auf
einmal ganz allein
viele können über diesen damals
erlittenen schock bis heute nicht
sprechen sie leben einfach mit ihm
weiter rund 120 erinnerungsstätten
entlang der küste sollen orte der trauer
und der trauer bewege
sein für schulklassen gehören besuche
zur pflicht das lernen aus der
vergangenheit als versprechen an die
zukunft für menschen die ans meer
zurückkehren haben die gemeinden
fluchtmöglichkeiten geschaffen es gilt
das vertrauen in den sich kümmern den
staat zurück zu gewinnen
wir brauchen vor allem eine langfristige
seelische betreuung der menschen
außerdem sind in ländlichen gebieten
viele baumaßnahmen noch nicht
abgeschlossen
auch nach zehn jahren haben wir längst
nicht alle unsere ziele erreicht
zurück in tomioka der ort liegt bis
heute in einer sperrzone das
atomkraftwerk von fukushima liegt etwa
sieben kilometer nördlich von hier bei
den explosionen in den reaktoren wurde
vor allem cäsium freigesetzt ein
radioaktiver stoff der einer
halbwertszeit von 30 jahren hat diese
gegend hier wird also noch sehr sehr
lange unbewohnbar bleiben
joko endo ist den tomioka geboren ihr
elternhaus mit gittern abgesperrt von
unkraut umwuchert die solarpaneele auf
dem dach brachten sie auf eine idee da
wo die verstrahlten und deswegen
brachliegenden reisfelder ihrer familie
waren hat sie eine solarfarm gegründet
zusammen mit 30 anderen familien in der
gegend die entschädigungen steckten sie
in 110.000 solarpaneele mit einer
nennleistung von 32 megawatt stunden die
idee hat allerdings einen haken es
belastet mich sehr aber in japan ist es
so dass es nur fünf oder sechs
stromkonzerne gibt die monopolisten sind
und deswegen müssen wir den strom nicht
nur an tepco verkaufen sondern auch noch
eine einspeise gebühr bezahlen
joko endoskop strom fließt
kostenpflichtig ausgerechnet ins netz
der betreiberfirma der unglücksreaktoren
dass die regierung die lage in fukushima
im vorfeld der olympischen spiele für
sicher und diese auch noch zu
wiederaufbau spielen erklärte ist für
nowitzki co ein schlechter witz
erst wenn das kontaminierte wasser in
der atom-ruine
das ganze verstrahlte erdreich entsorgt
sind und das kraftwerk sicher zurück
gebaut ist ist die lage unter kontrolle
und erst dann kann es einen wiederaufbau
geben an orten wie itate ist zehn jahre
nach der katastrophe von fukushima kein
platz für olympische träume angesichts
des täglichen albtraums
[Musik]